taking the stand for the last time today
Ryan gigs faced questions about a
statement he'd given to police after
allegedly headbutting his ex-girlfriend
in November 2020 the prosecution asked
why he'd said he was going to call 999
that evening the former Manchester
United player admitted he had no
intention of calling the police and said
he didn't know why he'd put that in his
statement Peter Wright QC argued it was
because Giggs wanted to create a
narrative that he'd been attacked not
his former partner Kate greville no was
gig's answer to that the police were
called to Giggs house that night by
greville's Sister when they arrived
Giggs told them that he'd hit his
ex-girlfriend in the lip the prosecution
asked why he hadn't explained that it
was an accident claiming it was because
Giggs had assaulted her but the defense
showed police body cam footage that
appeared to show the officer
interrupting Giggs mid-speech
Giggs also denies charges of controlling
and coercive Behavior against his former
partner he's claimed it was actually
greville who tried to control the
relationship the defense read out these
messages between the couple in court
which mentions stalking Giggs said
checking upon each other online was
common in their relationship in October
2017 Giggs asked grevel is your mum
going to stalk me now like her daughter
does she replied she better not in
another exchange of messages two years
later Kate greville asked Ryan Giggs who
are you talking to he responded her to
which she replied you were online before
and I was stalking you and then just
checking who you were talking to
the court also heard a love poem from
gigs to gravel in which he'd written
that stomach those abs those pictures
you send so I can keep tabs
more of their Communications will be
read to the jury who are expected to be
dismissed next week they'll have to
judge not only Ryan gigg's behavior on
one night two years ago but during his
relationship with a woman who says she
became a slave to his every need and
demand he denies all the charges Becky
Cottrell Sky News Manchester Crown Court